in the post Usain Bolt World Saturdays
100 meters final was always going to
carry added significance everyone eager
to see who could take bolts mantle and
be the sports news superstar well
whether Christian Coleman is that man
remains to be seen
off the track the American has missed
three drugs tests in 12 months
however on it Solman is a class apart
and he showed why as he won gold in 9.7
six seconds coming in ahead of defending
champion Justin Gatlin
[Applause]
you saying boy I'm just the new you know
crucial calming you know this just I
don't know it's an incredible feeling to
come out here in the add my name to a
list of guys you know legendary guys who
are world champions and now I can say
that I'm a world champion elsewhere on
the track history was made in the
women's 10,000 meters final she found
her son becoming the first ducks while
her to win the World title long jump
legend mike powell is on the crowd
seated Jay Galle take gold in his old
event the Jamaicans leap of eight point
six nine meters still well short of
powered world record of eight point nine
five meters set way back in 1991 well
day two ended like day one from Doha's
waterfronts with the mixed 50 kilometer
race walk and once again the humid
conditions made it tough for the
competitors China's Li and Rui winning
the women's race
[Applause]
whilst Japan Yuzuki Suzuki took men's
gold just ahead of 43 year-old Joe Viera
the Portuguese veteran defying the
difficult conditions to become the
oldest mound to win a medal in any event
pact al Jazeera